[Musique]
il y a quatre ans les deux associés de
la compagnie d'ébénisterie amic de
montréal le hic de ou et nicolas goupil
fabriquer des meubles sur mesure
ils vont faire la connaissance de pierre
laplante qui vient leur proposer un
projet un peu fou construire des vélos
en bois il y avait quand même des défis
techniques évidemment le bois c'est pas
un matériau qu'on manipule comme comme
de l'acier ou du carbone on en fait pas
ce qu'on veut
donc faut bien connaître le bois pierre
connaissait quand même pas mal le bois
pour y avoir pour en avoir travaillé
dans le passé nous ont amenés beaucoup
plus peut-être les techniques de
d'usinage la plupart des gens à qui j'en
parlais du impossible à réaliser
et pourtant je les ai réalisées avec
avec les dames et ébénisterie avec
piccolo et je vois que c'est quelque
chose qui fonctionne très très bien et
on peut retrouver les qualités
exceptionnelles du bois sur un véhicule
un vélo dont on avait oublié le
l'existence même depuis presque une
centaine d'amis
avait-on vélo est prêt pour l'essai
routier donc enlever 100 soit pouvoir
l'emporter joanes numainville a été
championne canadienne sur ouffe médaillé
d'or aux jeux panaméricains et 12e aux
jeux olympiques de londres
elle a accepté de tester pour la
première fois le vélo en bois piccolo
trois qualités il pas stif vraiment à
rapper j'ai trouvé dans le vin le puits
cas qu'on voit sur la gravelle on écoute
les brutes gravé alpes mais on sent
absolument ou presque pas l'aggraver
comme c'est comme c'est vraiment réduit
le mouvement
par exemple son intérêt sur les pavés en
belgique bien on s'entraîne vraiment -
le choc des pavés c'est comme si on
séduit près de 50% j'aurais prochain
vélo de compétition pour toi pourquoi
pas
[Musique]
l'entreprise piccolo veut produire 100
vélos par an des vélos haut de gamme car
le koup dépasser les 10 mille dollars
même s'ils veulent garder leur caractère
artisanal ces trois créateurs sont
convaincus que piccolo deviendra grand
robert frosi radio canada montréal